cell Locomotion results from coordinated
motion generated by different parts of
the cell and this is important for wound
healing or processes like neutrophil
extravasation which is important for
immune context
cytoskeletal element like actin Network
and actin bundle plays a vital role in
cell Locomotion it's a structured
process where the lamellipodium and
philopodium creates a stable contact
with the underlying surface
it begins with the Detachment of the
focal addition in the anterior part of
the cell
later on there is a Translate There is a
formation of new adhesion and the cell
body propels itself towards the anterior
part eventually there is a Detachment in
the posterior side and thereby the cell
starts move let's see the cell in action
there are several gdpses which are
important for this process like rack row
and cdc42